but I wouldn't go without these me
that's you there yes the little girl in
the middle and your mother's just behind
you yes
she's very beautiful woman
you were born in 1937 in Poland
what's your earliest memory
I think I was I think I was a very happy
child I adored my mother
I love my father
my aunt was somebody I was taken to see
and
the Matrix yes and then but you know it
it was quite difficult I think for my
for my grandfather because
he
he came from I think the yellow ruse and
he ended up in whatever looking for a
job and he came back
very disturbed increasingly disturbed
about what was happening in the rest of
Eastern Europe and did you have any
sense of this or were you effectively
protected from it at that time well I
was a little probably
two or three when it when that started
but my father told me but he said to my
grandmother he thought the family
should move and apparently my
grandmother said this was ridiculous
this was scaremongering and anyway who's
going to come to
for Java the little town
and what would they want
and as I said it was a very far-reaching
decision because
after the war only my father and I
survived everybody else had been
murdered
you say everybody else had been murdered
well my my uncle shulker
my uncle was deaf and mute I I loved him
shruggled all the time
spoke with his hands that that he did
find a wife
and they had one child
a little boy called
and was the brother I never had
but too with Stephan mute
and so I was brought up in a family
where half half the time everybody spoke
with their hands so anything odd never
really struck me
is that odd
and
when I lost I never forgave
myself
so let's
let's rewind slightly
the Nazis then occupy Poland and I know
this sounds like a really silly question
but how did things change at that point
what happened is they gradually the
German
started coming into whatever the
soldiers
and suddenly there was a curfew
and suddenly my grandfather couldn't
trade
and suddenly you had to wear
a mark
how old were you then so I was probably
six but you knew something wasn't right
well you know
you know when
you go into hiding suddenly I remember
suddenly
[Music]
um
my father and mother and I the family
split up
going
into hiding because there was they heard
there was going to be an action which
was a Roundup
and I the strange thing is that
I didn't question it
I did as I was told
and
we went back we went back to our home
but eventually
you're like run out I like red out yes
we were told we were given an hour
to pack whatever we needed to pack
there was going to be two camps built
near us
one wasn't sobibor and the other one was
going to be in a small village called
adampo I suddenly realized many years
later
that I didn't like silver Birches
because silver Birches were on the way
that we walked
from whatever to Adam Paul
I always knew
when
somebody was coming I knew I had a sense
of what wasn't right and I remember that
one particular day
and I were doing something
outside
the house
and I heard a noise
and I saw
the little Jeeps coming
he couldn't hear and he couldn't speak
so I took his hand
and I he knew that if I tugged him here
to come
because by this time Malco was dead
my uncle
is was dead as well you were looking
after him pardon you were looking after
him then I was looking after him I
grabbed his hand
and I pulled it so he knew he had to
come
and we ran into the nearest barn
and I did what we've done maybe
two or three times before I ran down to
the middle of it and dived into the
straw there were always lots and lots of
straw there
and I thought was following me
but I felt around
and he wasn't there
and I could hear them
he couldn't I could hear them
the
and
I couldn't call him because he wouldn't
he wouldn't know
and I was deciding whether I had time to
go and get him and as I was about to do
it
I remember he was standing like this by
the drawer
the door swung open
and they saw him
and they picked him up literally by the
Scruff of his neck
and my last sight of my lovely cousin
was his back
and his legs kicking
I never saw him again
and I think
in a funny way that's when the war
reached me because it wasn't comfortable
and it wasn't nice sleeping my mother
used to sleep they had nice things like
there there'd be a space for three
so my mother always slept in the middle
so that I slept next to her
suddenly I wasn't sleeping next to my
mother
it was
it was difficult
it was the last winter of the war
and I got sick
and whatever my mother did and whatever
they they didn't have medication do you
remember being ill yes I do I remember
my mother
putting cold compresses on me my mother
was one of world's
give us and she was very kind to
everybody
and I think losing her was probably one
of the worst things that happened and I
remembered very clearly
sometime during the night
I think because I was Restless too
there was a tap tap on a window on the
side of it small little side window was
remembered I found it when I went back
the side
and
my mother sat up and listened
and there it was again so she got up and
she opened the window I asked my father
and he said yes that's exactly what he
said it was a very quick conversation
he said hi you must come
Tomorrow there's an action
so he warned your mother yes and she
said I can't
Go's not well
and she said bring her with and she said
she'll never make it
and whether it was a patrol or a
searchlight I don't know
my mother closed the window he
disappeared and she laid down behind
beside me
and probably
for as long as I live
I will always wonder
how she got through that night
how she made
the decisions she made
and was it right
I might have survived without her there
and if I didn't they were young enough
to have other children
but she laid down beside me
and me
tried to sleep
and very early that morning
there were the usual sounds of the
island that's grouping Jeeps they always
came from outside
Jeeps yelling screaming roundups
and we were just lying there
and then suddenly there was a whack on
the door
and my mother with great dignity
got on her knees
took me in her arms
gave me a hug
a kiss
and with great dignity I'm I've always
remembered she didn't run she didn't
make a sound
she walked to the door
opened the door
and closed it firmly behind her
and I waited for her to come back
like she you sometimes did
but she didn't come back
and there was more and more sound and
more noises more or yelling and
screaming
and I decided I'd go and look for her
so I opened the door
and there were ocean they were shoving
them all
in front of the well
in the center of the village
and at first I couldn't see her
now my mother and I always
made eye contact
and then suddenly
I saw her and they were lining them up
in front of the world
and she was very calm and she was
talking to somebody
and I couldn't understand it we always
made eye contact
she didn't look back at the house
did she see you do you think
of course
she didn't look back at the house
she didn't love me she just did what
they were saying so I decided that
I would go down and take a hand the way
I always did
and as I was about to go and I was
barefoot
somebody shouted an order
they started to shoot
and I saw her fall
and I saw the blood on this on the snow
and in that I always say
in that time I absolutely grew up I knew
I mustn't make a sound I knew what she
had done and why she had done it
I I I I I I couldn't believe it
and then I did a little bit of
self-healing
I told myself that my mother
is probably injured and she pretended to
be dead because it had happened that
people pretended to and they were saved
and of course my father had been there
the night before
he actually couldn't get back so he was
in the barn the next morning and he saw
it as well
he couldn't do anything about it
and
I convinced myself
that she
pretended to be to be dead but she
wasn't really because she was with my
father
and in a way it helped me get through
to the end of the war
and when my father that and then that
was quite traumatic because
people started we were probably one of
the last to be liberated
and
people started coming out of the woods
where they were hiding there were lots
of people living and hiding in the woods
but no one came for me
and then suddenly one day
there he was there was my father
dirty skinny but my father he got hold
of me
he laughed he cried he cuddled me
but by this time
I was so into the fact that he had come
to save her
I said to him
after all that I said where's Mama
because she still believed she might be
alive
so he said hanechka
Mama's not coming back Mama died
you saw it
I said no no you were there you took her
said no honey
she died
and I remember
him shaking me
because apparently for
a couple of hours I didn't utter one
sound
and he thought that the curse of the
deaf and the mute might have got to me
and eventually
I did start
I did start talking about it
it's extraordinary to meet you
as you are now and to hear what happened
to you it's kind of almost kind of
awe-inspiring in some ways you know
your mother would be so proud of you as
well and she made such a sacrifice but
and it's my revenge
it's actually my revenge
for her and everybody else
and you speak of your story as well
don't you through the Holocaust
Education trust in schools and you tell
it yes yes and you know they they always
every now and again you get I think I
told you the kids said do you do you
tell your story because you hate the
Germans
and I said no I tell my story
because I care for you
and beware
people who promise you the world
and actually
don't
so you know make your own judgments
look at the book not discover
oh we thank you so much for telling your
story